اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم مقتل 11د من ضباط وجنود الجيش
الاسرائيلي في معارك قطاع غزه خلال
الساعات ال4 الماضيه والمتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعلن تدمير القدرات العسكريه
لحماس شمال القطاع ويؤكد توسع العمليات في
خانيونس وكتائب القسام تقول ان مقاوميها
قناصوا اربعه جنود اسرائيليين شرق مخيم
البريج وسط القطاع ودمروا دبابه كافا جنوب
خانيونس هذا في حين اعلنت وزاره الصحه في
غزه استشهاد
126 شخصا في قصف جوي ومدفعي اسرائيلي خلال
الساعات ال4 الماضيه بلينكن يقول من تل
ابيب انه سيبحث مستقبل الحمله العسكريه في
غزه ويعلن ان زعماء تركيا والاردن وقطر
والامارات والسعوديه مصممون على منع اتساع
دائره الصراع مسؤولون اسرائيليون يقولون
انهم سيبلغون بلينكن بان اسرائيل لن تسمح
للفلسطينيين بالعوده الى شمال غزه ما لم
تفرش حماس عن مزيد من الرهائن وهنيه يؤكد
ان الاحتلال لن يستطيع استرداد اسراه
مطلقا الا بالافراج عن جميع الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في سجونه قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
مدينه طول كرم وتغتال ثلاثه مقاومين
فلسطينيين وتنكل بجثمان احدهم وتقتحم
نابلوس وتحاصر مخيمي عسكر وبلاطه ووسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان قاده الامن حذروا
نتنياهو من اقتراب الضفه الغربيه من تصعيد
كبير جرح في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف سياره
بمحيط تشييع القيادي في حزب الله وسام
طويل جنوبي لبنان الحزب يعلن استهداف
قياده المنطقه الشماليه للجيش الاسرائيلي
في صفد بطائرات مسيره ردا على اغتيال
العرور وطويل ووزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
يتبنى اغتيال وسام طويل والجيش الاسرائيلي
يشن سلسله غارات ويكثف قصفه المدفعي على
بلدات حدوديه الى
اللقاء